Antenne dans 1 minute.
Oui je suis là, je suis sur le plateau dans 30 secondes, j'attends juste le communiqué.
Merci.
Tiens
- Ça vient d'arriver ?
- Tout juste
Il faut que tu cales quelques mots à la fin du journal, on a pas eu le temps de faire une séquence
Et c'est quoi? C'est une sorte de test c'est ça ?
Bon en gros je t'explique. C'est des scientifiques français qui ont trouvé un moyen de quantifier l'amour.
T'es en couple, tu passes quelques analyses, tu fais quelques tests
et ensuite ils sont capables d'analyser et de quantifier ton amour.
D'accord mais... moi j'ai besoin de mettre du concret là-dedans.
C'est bon là, ça va ?
Oui.
Bon, et le gouvernement a autorisé le truc ? On peut faire le test ?
Justement, Patrick veut que tu parles de ça. En gros on cherche des volontaires
pour faire les premiers tests et si ça se passe bien, ça sera autorisé pour tout le monde.
- Antenne dans 10 !
- Ok, bon je vais pouvoir nous caler ça.
- C'est bon.
- Merci.
5, 4, 3, 2
T'as vu le truc qui fait le buzz ?
Ah oui le test d'amour ?
- Oui, tout le monde en parle.
- Pourquoi ?
Ouais c'est vrai.
Tu veux le faire ?
Quoi ?
- Tu veux faire le test ?
- Non non...
Je disais ça comme ça.
Moi ça ne me dérangerait pas mais bon.
Comment ça ?
- C'est bien là ?
- Oui t'es très bien.
Ça veut dire quoi "mais bon" ?
Mais bon si je n'étais pas sûre de notre couple je t'aurais pas demandé en mariage.
Je sais. Mais les gens le font pour le fun.
Ouais, comme tu veux.
Ça m'est égal.
- On y va ?
- Ouais .
- Allez hop !
- Ok.
Ça va être dingue !
De quoi ?
Ton enterrement de vie de garçon.
C'est toi qui le fait ?
Bah oui c'est moi.
- Tu l'organises ?
- J'organise tout ! Mais je te dis rien.
Ça va être fou !
J'en avais fait un pour un pote, ça a un peu mal tourné
ça s'est fini à l'hôpital, coma éthylique
C'est un peu chaud.
Je veux faire le test.
Veuillez répondre aux questions suivantes instinctivement, le plus rapidement possible.
D'accord.
Nom, prénom.
Ferrand, Milo.
Profession.
Je... j'essaie d'écrire un livre...
Écrivain.
Croyez-vous en l'amour ?
Oui.
Croyez-vous en l'amour éternel ?
Distinguez-vous l'amour de l'affection ?
Oui.
Vos parents sont-ils encore ensemble ?
Avez-vous déjà été infidèle ?
Non.
Avez-vous déjà pensé à être infidèle ?
Vous considérez-vous comme possessif ?
Non.
Mentez-vous souvent à votre amant, à votre amante ?
Avez-vous des choses à cacher ?
Non.
Non !
Merci.
Ça va, ça a été ?
Ouais, ça s'est bien passé.
Tu passes bientôt ?
Non c'est bon je l'ai fait.
Il faut attendre le médecin, j'ai pris mon ticket.
Ok.
Alors, on a les résultats, enfin les estimations
- Les quoi ?
- Les estimations.
Alors je vous explique, ces tests ne sont pas à prendre au pied de la lettre.
En tout cas pas pour l'instant. Les résultats reflètent l'état de l'amour
que vous portez l'un à l'autre, à ce jour.
Les résultats peuvent être différents si vous revenez demain par exemple
L'amour varie constamment, c'est pas une
une valeur linéaire.
- Vous comprenez ?
- Oui oui.
D'accord. Alors.
Ce que j'ai sous les yeux, c'est le résultat gracieux, le résultat simpliste des analyses.
Pour pouvoir avoir des résultats beaucoup plus complets
il y a des frais supplémentaires d'analyse en laboratoire et caetera.
Donc...
D'après ce que j'ai sous les yeux, écoutez, pour moi ça à l'air d'aller.
Vous vous aimez, ça il n'y a pas de doutes.
Je peux pas vous dire à combien de pourcentage par exemple
madame aime monsieur ou monsieur aime madame, pour ça il faudrait avoir
les résultats complets.
- Mais donc c'est bien ?
- C'est bien les résultats sont bons quoi ?
-Ah oui oui...
Le seul détail c'est qu'il semble y avoir
une tierce personne dans votre dans votre histoire là.
Comment ça ?
Alors, j'ai dis "il semble" il y avoir une tierce personne...
J'ai compris mais ça veut dire quoi?
Ça veut dire que l'un de vous deux
Comment dire ? L'un de vous deux
exprimerait de l'amour pour une tierce personne.
Qui ?
Je sais pas. Pour plus de détails là il faudrait
avoir les résultats complets.
- Ça peut pas être un bug ?
- C'est combien?
Alors étant donné que le test n'est pas encore publique
là vous bénéficiez de la formule la plus accessible
celle où les recherches sont faites sur le temps libre des chercheurs.
Vous aurez un résultat dans les 3 mois on va dire.
En revanche, vous avez la formule plus complète comme celle-ci
qui là vous permet d'avoir un résultat complet en seulement quelques heures.
Donc là il y a le charabia médical,
et puis la synthèse très claire qui vous permet là d'avoir un résultat...
- C'est combien ?
- La formule ? c'est 1500 euros.
- Je peux te parler 5 minutes ?
- Et celle en 3 mois ?
C'est celle-ci ,1500 euros.
Ah non, la formule express, c'est 6000 euros.
- Merci beaucoup mais on va s'en passer.
- Pourquoi on s'en passerait ?
Parce que ça représente le budget de notre mariage, voilà pourquoi.
Milo, ce test n'est pas fiable, ça sert à rien.
Oui Maman !
Oui ! ça va les amoureux ?
Ça va et vous Nicole ?
- Oh oui tu sais, nous ça va toujours.
- Qui c'est ?
- C'est Milo et Flora !
Ah coucou les chéris!
Coucou !
- Ça va bien ?
- Ouais !
Oui oui, vous voulez quoi ?
C'est juste pour savoir si tout ce passe bien
si vous avez bien reçu l'argent pour le mariage
- Oui ! Oui merci beaucoup !
- Où vous en étiez, tout ça.
- Faut préparer !
- Ouais on prépare bien là.
On a presque fini.
Voilà, on est en voiture là, on est sur la route.
Ah, soyez prudents.
Voilà, on vous rappelle ce soir.
- Oui je...
- Au revoir !
Bisous *Raccroche*
Pourquoi t'es méchant comme ça avec eux ?
- Je suis pas méchant...
- T'es pas méchant ?
Ils me mettent la pression c'est tout.
Ça va ils demandent deux trois nouvelles, c'est bon on peut leur en donner
c'est eux qui payent tout le mariage.
Mais si, vous voyez pas c'est...
c'est l'acteur, qui joue dans Game of Thrones
et il est aussi dans le Seigneur des Anneaux
- Sean Penn
- Sean Bean
Sean Bean ! Voilà, et Sean Bean il meurt dans tous les films
Il meurt et il meurt super bien Sean Bean
Nous on a vu quoi récemment au cinéma ?
Je sais pas
Doriane elle m'emmène voir des films et j'm'endors donc...
Ouais ça va Madame JaimeQueLesTransformers
C'est pas vrai, le dernier j'ai pas aimé.
Ouais enfin, moi je te parle de vrai cinéma.
Et puis c'est pas parce que c'est lent que c'est nul
Non, mais moi quand je vais au cinéma j'aime me divertir.
J'vais aux toilettes.
Et voilà la salle, avec son charme très atypique
C'est vraiment une perle rare dans le domaine de la réception.
On pensait mettre la grande scène à droite à côté des portes,
et des tables un peu partout dans la salle, qu'on enlèverait ensuite
pour laisser place au dance floor
d'ailleurs faut qu'vous me passiez le numéro du DJ, dont vous m'avez parlé
que je prenne ses coordonnées.
Voilà le panneau qui est arrivé aujourd'hui
Et c'est tout pour le check d'aujourd'hui. Alors ça va ? Pas trop stressés ?
Là on a pas le temps d'être stressés !
Oui c'est normal, je comprends.
C'est quoi ça Flora ?
Quoi ?
Ton rire, et ton sourire là, c'est nouveau... c'est faux-cul. C'est quoi ?
De quoi tu parles ?
Maintenant tu me fais ça depuis des semaines.
Je vous laisse...
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? C'est le lieu qui te plaît plus ?
Tu repenses encore à ton ex ?
Ah non...
Quand on était en boite je t'ai vu avec lui.
Il était là Milo, j'allais pas l'ignorer.
C'est pas à lui que tu envoies des SMS, toute la journée, par hasard ?
Mais ça va plus toi.
Et maintenant tu caches ton téléphone. Ça c'est nouveau ?
Ça va avec le rire, le sourire de merde ?
C'est à cause du test ?
Tu me prends la tête à cause des résultats ?
Mais bien sûr c'est à cause du test ! Les résultats scientifiquement prouvés ! Bien sûr !
Milo, le gars l'a dit, c'est une première version, t'es con ou quoi ?
Écoute
ne prends pas en compte ce test. Je te jure, je vois comment toi tu peux...
t'imaginer des...
C'est pas ce que tu crois.
J'aurais besoin de votre pièce d'identité, s'il vous plaît.
Si vous voulez bien parapher et signer à la dernière page s'il vous plaît.
Pas vraiment le temps de tout lire !
Très bien. Merci. Et bien écoutez on vous envoie tout ça pour dans 1h30, 2h.
- Je vais attendre ici.
- Pardon ?
Je vais attendre ici.
Tu l'as pas fait, tu l'as pas fait...
Tiens !
T'es content là, t'es satisfait, tu sais tout là ! Tu veux savoir autre chose ?
Vas-y pose moi des questions, je t'écoute là.
Je voulais te l'annoncer pendant le mariage.
Ça aurait été beau nan ?
Non, parce que si monsieur ne sait pas tout sur tout, avec l'égo de monsieur, il faut que monsieur fasse sa crise.
Parce que monsieur a toujours eu tout ce qu'il voulait
et moi par contre on s'en bat les couilles.
Je peux aller me faire foutre.
Tu t'es demandé une seule fois comment je vivais le mariage, la pression, l'organisation ?
Tu ne m'as pas demandé une seule fois comment ça allait !
Je me sens comme une merde ! Voilà !
À devoir dépendre de toi et de ta famille parce que c'est eux qui payent tout !
Je me sens comme une merde à ne pas pouvoir t'aider à écrire ton bouquin,
à ne pas t'inspirer !
Mais toi, tout ce que tu trouves à faire pendant cette période c'est passer un putain de test
pour savoir à quel point on serait compatible ?
Je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire ce résultat :
une tierce personne, je n'en sais rien !
Peut être que parfois oui je pense à mon ex avec qui j'ai passé 6 ans de ma vie.
Voilà parce que c'est une relation qui m'a aidée, qui m'a forgée, qui m'a construite.
Mais ce n'est pas de l'amour, c'est de l'attachement, c'est de l'affection.
C'est toi que j'aime.
Je suis au maximum là. C'est tout ce que je peux t'offrir.
Tu ne veux pas de moi, trouve quelqu'un d'autre.
Monsieur, vos résultats.
Personne sui...